so i don't really know football but
buddha baker or butter baker do you guys
know this guy
no no so he got some racist messages i
think it was an instagram
right mm-hmm so it's a lot of bad words
and the 49ers
[Laughter]
the 49ers are actually going to try to
find this guy and ban this ban this
person from games for life
which is cool because usually there's no
consequences when you do something bad
on social media say that all the time
people could just run up on your
instagram and just talk [ __ ] remember
back in the day someone run up on you in
junior high he's
like pop that's the problem you got a
bunch of [ __ ] out there
who have no consequences yeah they're so
they're gonna try and
find him and ban them for the games for
life okay can they what
does that mean pro baller no not the no
yeah what's up monkey bleep bleep you
gonna get a bounty on your
your [ __ ] monkey ass head you [ __ ]
dirty inward
i'm trying to sound like trying to go
after the knees you think we blind you
dirty
monkey nick you look at me you [ __ ]
slaves jesus
before we blow your knees out you
[ __ ]
[Applause]
hey you know he shouted that last one
you know he shouted that last one at the
time
you know he shouted that last one i know
you're serious i see now i miss
one mispronunciation it was uh great
grammar i was like yeah he did that
he cried yeah i was funny because he did
it
yeah i know that last one because he
could have ended on monday
he could end it let me just what i don't
get is why doesn't
twitter take like just banned or
instagram just banned them for life too
like the emails whatever you create
obviously you can create other emails
create profiles just yeah it's just get
rid of that account forever like
the you know trump's trying to do a
better job of it of controlling social
media how negative
is how they influence the the election
stuff like that like it's just the wild
west man
it's so dude i think about all the time
like how can someone just run up on your
ig and just remember that where where
were we at when i received those uh
racist uh dms where we over in phoenix
phoenix yeah just out of like nowhere
it's like oh that like yeah i don't know
no um
no we're not in the hotel yeah
um we had dinner and they were bad man
for no reason yeah
some trolls why would they go after you
oh come on they dm it was just like
very similar to that yeah it was you
know something it went uh
and he didn't have as many he didn't
have like multiple paragraphs
no it was two messages it was just two
messages and it was just like
okay like that's crazy though but i
think about it like
you know that's what
but the problem is there's a lot of
mental sickness out there yeah
there's that and there's also just a lot
of losers
there's so many losers that they don't
have anything going on i think it's wow
that someone just
like has the energy to go to a person
and just
say some [ __ ] here's the thing chapelle
they have nothing else going on yeah
that's the highlight of the day and
hopefully you respond or hopefully you
see it
yeah that's how like to me i just feel
sorry for them because like
like if you're gonna leave a negative
youtube comment or a dm it's like
that's the hot that's the highlight of
your day and they talk about it and if
you respond
oh my god and no and none of them are
getting any girls dog no one's gonna be
like hey look what i sent to chappelle
look at
i call him the n-word no girl's like oh
that's so dope let me [ __ ] you
so stupid that never happened that game
don't work in the history of the world
that's never happened that's not how
game works
let me let me delete mine how did big
sean do it
hey cat do you give me hate yeah like
were they
it's a lot of like either racist like
asian stuff
or like uh commenting like on my body or
like
i my worth like what i do here and stuff
like that it's usually that it's like
usually being a girl and being asian
and you're a great person and they cut
but they comment like oh that's why you
just
do this for firing the kid uh it's a lot
of like
[ __ ] you work 40 hours a week and don't
make as much as cats
it's a lot of stuff like that where it's
like oh you bring
nothing to the show like what do you do
or like
oh you're only there because uh the guys
need like
some a hot girl to like be behind the
camera which first of all thank you for
calling me hot
but you know what it's like you wearing
like middle school or elementary school
where the kid would punch the girl
yeah that's like that's their way of
flirting yeah that's these losers
trying to you know i think a lot of
these [ __ ] just want to reply
yeah a lot of them just want to respond
because i mean i mean there's one time
like i
actually did reply to some [ __ ] and they
go oh i didn't think you'd reply and i
go
why the [ __ ] you talking to me man like
you could have just said something cool
you know but i i can't believe i fed
into it yeah like a jackass
i don't know why i did that but this is
my thing with social media like
think of anything you've ever done so
you're doing stand-up let's say
uh current times you're just starting to
stand up let's say
you got online and this is what you're
getting done with cheerleading and you
made a video like
hey everybody i'm thinking of doing
stand-up what do you think
the comments you would get lit up so bad
no one's even like yeah chappelle do it
never your mouth think of you from
boxing to doing stand-up yeah
you would get so discouraged you get so
many negative comments
so why would you give a [ __ ] what they
think about any show you do
or anything you would never take their
advice oh on
ever if you did you would neither one of
you would ever be here okay
dude you would never attempt comedy if
you listened to social media
you would never you'd never do anything
ever social media wasn't even really
like that when i started that's what i'm
saying if it was yeah yeah yeah
like so why would you put any vested
interest in imagine if i go i started
cheerleading on social media
think about the comments now but think
if you took the advice on that yeah so
why would you take advice from you from
anything
stand up podcasting like if you knew
what was good
yeah for the show you'd be doing it
[ __ ] yeah you'd be doing it instead
you're in my comments section in a
conversation because you're fooling the
people and that's for all you out there
because
you ain't [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] you hate me
i'm mad as hell man i'm hot no one cares
i did
you ain't a goddamn bot that's my reply
to everybody
you're so mad [ __ ] yeah all the way here
you ain't [ __ ] you came all the way here
you came in the moderator
go create something go do something
though so that's where the aim is
come on man i believe in y'all
but i can't have that anymore come on
man don't get lost with my awkwardness
talk don't talk brendon
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this from a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song